prince harry and meghan markle's
daughter lillabet turned one over the
weekend and a source is giving e.t all
the details inside her first birthday
bash well they've chosen lilybet which
is the nickname that was given to the
queen when she was a little girl so it's
deeply personal and really an incredibly
intimate name for the queen but the
couple have made it clear that they will
refer to her and they expect others to
refer to her as lily megan and harry
just shared a new image of their
beautiful baby girl there's lillabet a
candid shot at her birthday celebration
wearing a blue outfit and a matching bow
her best accessory her red locks just
like her dad and brother archie
the sword says megan and harry
celebrated lily's birthday at frogmore
cottage with several family members on
saturday on the guest list zara tindall
and peter phillips princess anne's
children along with their spouses and
little ones our source adds that it was
an opportunity for the kids who are
close in age to spend some time at
frogmore together the birthday was
low-key and relaxed with birthday cake
for all the kids to enjoy but notably
absent from the festivities prince
william kate middleton and other members
of the royal family turns out they were
all traveling to different parts of the
uk to visit those who are celebrating
queen elizabeth's platinum jubilee at et
source is adamant the events were not
planned to avoid it quote it's simply a
coincidence they fell on the same day
there was no intended slight the duke
and duchess of cambridge tweeted their
well wishes to lily but while taking
their children on a previously scheduled
visit to wales also missing the
celebration queen elizabeth but a source
confirmed to e.t she met her namesake
for the first time face to face last
thursday after the trooping the color
event which also included a reunion with
her big brother three-year-old archie
she hasn't seen archie for nearly two
years now and she hasn't seen harry for
well over a year so she would have been
i'm sure delighted to have got to see
him and megan and how much was discussed
is is hard to know i think the queen
particularly given that she's not 100 at
the moment would have just wanted this
to be a warm encounter the sussex has
made the trip across the pond for queen
elizabeth's jubilee honoring her 70
years on the throne
as the four day celebration came to an
end the queen shared her gratitude in a
statement writing in part quote when it
comes to how to mark 70 years as your
queen there is no guidebook to follow it
really is a first but i have been
humbled and deeply touched that so many
people have taken to the streets to
celebrate my platinum jubilee
[Music]
you